>> Dana: NOW, WE HAVE A
DISTURBING VIDEO TO SHOW YOU.
A GROUP OF ANGRY PROTESTERS
SHOWING UP OUTSIDE OF
MITCH McCONNELL'S HOUSE THIS
WEEKEND.
RECOVERING FROM A BROKEN
SHOULDER WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
>> MURDER TURTLE.
MURDER TURTLE.
>> WE KNOW YOUR HOME.
EVERYTHING YOU STAND FOR.
>> THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT IT IS.
JUST STAB THE IN THE HEART.
>> Dana: YES.
THAT IS WHAT SHE SAID.
FOR POSTING THE NAMES AND
EMPLOYERS OF TRUMP DONORS TO
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY ARE ACCUSING THE PEOPLE OF
FEELING A CAMPAIGN OF HATE.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A DANGEROUS
THING TO DO, GREG.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE SO, BUT
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
RHETORIC IS TIED TO ACTION.
A CONSERVATIVE THANKS A LIBERAL
IS WRONG, BUT A LEFTIST THINGS A
LIBERAL IS EVIL.
IF YOU ARE PART OF THE
RESISTANCE, THEN YOU ARE AGAINST
THE RESISTANCE.
THEY ARE BASICALLY NORMALIZING
INTIMIDATION TACTICS.
WILL THEY HAVE BLOOD ON THEIR
HANDS?
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING
TO DO THIS TO US AT SOME POINT.
WE WILL BE DEMONIZED.
[LAUGHS]
>> Donna: BY THE WAY.
LOOK, THEIR NAMES ARE PUBLISHED.
IN FACT, I LEARNED OVER THE
WEEKEND THAT ALL OF
DONALD TRUMP'S MAJOR SUPPORTERS
IN LOUISIANA, DONALD TRUMP HAS
RAISED OVER 690 --
$690,000.
I'M READING THE STORY, AND ALL
OF THE SUDDEN, I READ THE LIST
OF ALL OF DONALD TRUMP'S DONORS.
DID I RUN TO SOCIAL MEDIA AND
SAY, I'M NOT GOING TO COME TO
YOUR GROCERY STORE?
KNOW.
THIS IS A TACTIC THAT PEOPLE ARE
USING IN THIS "POLARIZED
ENVIRONMENT" TO KIND OF CALL
PEOPLE OUT.
I THINK IT'S THE WRONG WAY TO DO
THIS.
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT HAS
PROTECTED DONATIONS THROUGH
CITIZENS UNITED, SAYING THAT
BASICALLY YOU CAN DONATE
ANONYMOUSLY.
IT'S YOUR RIGHT TO DONATE TO A
CAMPAIGN, BUT IT MAY BE A RIGHT
TO PRIVACY AS WELL.
>> Greg: IT SAFER.
I MEAN, ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY
ARE SANE, BY THE WAY.
DISARM.
THEY ARE INCITING VIOLENCE
AGAINST AN INDIVIDUAL, AND THEN
SAYING, DON'T PROTECT YOURSELF
WHEN PEOPLE SHOW UP OUTSIDE YOUR
HOME LIKE THEY DID
MITCH McCONNELL.
THE CHANT OF THE THINGS THEY
CHANTED.
EVERY SINGLE SENATOR AND
CONGRESSMAN WOULD BE CONFRONTED
BY A MEDIA MEMBER, SAYING THAT
YOU HAVE TO CONDEMN.
WILL YOU CONDEMN?
THEY WOULD BE ALL OVER THE
HEADLINES, ALL OVER THE NETWORK
NEWS CYCLE.
THIS IS BEING BURIED.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO
VIOLENCE.
BECAUSE, AT SOME POINT, SOMEONE
IS GOING TO COME OUT WITH A
WEAPON WHEN SOMEONE TRESPASSES
IN THEIR HOME.
>> Katie: SITUATIONS LIKE THAT
NEVER TEND TO END WELL.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED AS A
RESULT OF THE POLICE GOING TO
THE WRONG HOUSE.
THERE ARE SERIOUS VIOLENT
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS.
MITCH CALLED THE POLICE.
ALL THE PEOPLE WERE INTERVIEWED
AND ASKED IF THEY HAD INTENTIONS
OF WANTING TO ASSASSINATE HIM.
PEOPLE SHOWING UP AT PEOPLE'S
PRIVATE HOMES IS NOTHING NEW.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
20-30 YEARS.
IT'S JUST NOW AMPED UP.
THEY THINK IT'S JUSTIFIED,
BECAUSE IF IT'S A WHITE
SUPREMACIST IN THE HOUSE, THEN
OF COURSE, THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
SHOW UP.
SEE FOR IT CAN SCARY, DONNA.
>> Donna: ALL MY.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS, I HAVE
PROTECTION, GIVEN MY OPINION IN
THE PUBLIC SPHERE.
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S NOT EASY TO
LIVE THIS WAY, WHETHER YOU ARE
IN A MANSION OR A PALACE OR EVEN
JUST WALKING AROUND.
LET ME JUST SAY SOMETHING.
I USED TO LEAD PROTESTS IN MY
YOUTH.
NONVIOLENT PROTESTS, WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
I HAVE COUNSELED PEOPLE HOW TO
DO THIS TO ABIDE BY THE LAWS,
NOT USE BULLHORNS AND ALL THAT.
WE SEEN PROTESTS NOW FROM
HONG KONG WHERE EVERYDAY
CITIZENS ARE OUT THERE
PROTESTING GOVERNMENT ACTION.
BUT WE SHOULD DO IT IN A
NONVIOLENT WAY, BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT SEPARATE US FROM
THE OTHER CIVILIZED WORLD, WE
HAVE LAWS THAT PROTECT PEOPLE
WHO PROTEST.
>> Greg: PLACES LIKE MEDIA
MATTERS.
THERE WAS ANOTHER GUY NAMED DAN
PFEIFFER.
THESE ARE PEOPLE IN GROUPS.
FOX NEWS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING
FOX NEWS IS ACTUALLY AN ENGINE
OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS PAINTING
A TARGET ON US.
JONES ON TWITTER, BASICALLY
SAYING THAT HE IS GOING TO HAVE
TO SIT AT HIS HOUSE AND PROTECT
HIS FAMILY.
HE IS GOING TO HOPE THAT THIS
DOESN'T END UP SENDING SOME
CRAZY TO HIS HOUSE.